a sus 55 años el chef javier vargas
tiene 11 ceviche y así un respetable
prestigio
pero él teme que su comida nunca más
pueda ser degustada por sus clientes con
la nueva cuarentena que no permite la
atención del público sus restaurantes se
encuentran a punto de quebrar con estas
restricciones últimas del gobierno lo
que está haciendo es conducirnos a una
muerte anunciada' en los restaurantes en
el perú en medio de la segunda ola que
golpea a perú las autoridades ordenaron
que los restaurantes solo trabajen por
la modalidad de la entrega a domicilio
algo que no es posible para el 75% de
ellos el gremio afirma que existen miles
de negocios gastronómicos que no pueden
sostener planilla ni cubrir sus costos
operativos en la situación crítica no de
los 200.000 restaurantes que había antes
de la pandemia ya 70 mil cerraron sus
puertas definitivamente eso hace que al
día de hoy más de medio millón de
personas hayan perdido su puesto de
trabajo directamente estamos hablando de
moxos cocineros gente de limpieza gente
que trabaja directamente los
restaurantes el gobierno peruano anunció
un fondo de más de 500 millones de
dólares
para que las micro y pequeñas empresas
más golpeadas por la pandemia no
colapsen estamos apoyando a las empresas
a las familias y vamos a apoyar a los
trabajadores para que este costo no sea
tan grande
javier vargas considera que la ayuda no
es suficiente
[Música]
y le está organizando un cacerolazo
virtual con los chefs y cocineros del
perú para exigir al gobierno no permitir
que la gastronomía peruana muera por el
cob y 19